.
SO GET TO THE POLLS OR YOU'LL
GET THE GOVERNMENT YOU DESERVE.
IT'S THAT SIMPLE.
HERE WITH REACTION, KELLYANNE
CONWAY, MIKE HUCKABEE AND FOX
NEWS CONTRIBUTOR ARI FLEISCHER.
KELLYANNE, WE START WITH YOU.
YOU'RE GOOD WITH NUMBERS.
WHEN WE GO BACK TO 2016, IF WE
TAKE THE THREE SWING STATES THAT
DONALD TRUMP WON, COMBINED TOTAL
VOTES, 70,000.
IT'S NOT A LOT.
IF YOU LOOK AT 2020 AND YOU LOOK
AT ARIZONA, GEORGIA, WISCONSIN,
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT 43,000
VOTES, KELLYANNE.
SO WHEN I LOOK AT THE POLLS IN
GEORGIA AND I LOOK AT THE POLLS
IN NEVADA, ARIZONA, ALTHOUGH A
POLL HAS BLAKE MASTERS UP BY
THREE TODAY, AND I LOOK AT THOSE
POLLS AM I WRONG IN BELIEVING
THAT PROBABLY EVERY ONE OF THOSE
RACES THE POWER IN THE SENATE
WILL BE DETERMINED BY TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF VOTES AND NOT
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS?
>> YOU'RE RIGHT.
THAT'S THE WAY THE ELECTIONS
HAVE BEEN GOING AND THAT'S WHY
HER CALLED SWING STATES.
THEY SIT ON THE RAZOR'S EDGE.
IT DEPENDS ON TURNOUT AND
MOTIVATION AND WHAT I CALL
INVESTING IN THE NONSEXY PART OF
POLITICS.
EVERYBODY SEES THE ADS, THE
RALLIES, THE CAMPAIGN, THE
CANDIDATE DIRECT APPEALS, THE TV
INTERVIEWS.
WHAT THEY DON'T SEE IS WHO IS
INVESTING IN DATA AND DIGITAL.
HOW MANY VOLUNTEERS YOU HAVE,
HOW MANY VOTER CONTACTS HAVE YOU
MADE.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE DNC IS
DOING, BUT THE RNC HAS DONE A
GAIT JOB ON THIS.
THEY RAISED OVER $300 MILLION
AND SPENT IT.
THEY HAVE OVER 100 MILLION VOTER
CONTACTS.
THINK ABOUT THAT.
YOU'RE CALLING VOTERS AND YOU'RE
THE PARTY TALKING ABOUT
INFLATION, CRIME, EDUCATION,
IMMIGRATION, BORDER SECURITY,
NATIONAL SECURITY, FINANCIAL
SECURITY.
PHYSICAL SECURITY IN YOUR
COMMUNITIES.
THEY HAVE OVER ONE MILLION
VOLUNTEERS.
YOU SEE THAT ALL OF THESE
CANDIDATES HAVE BEEN VERY
WELL-RESOURCED.
I THINK WHAT HAS HAPPENED LATE
IN THE GAME, PEOPLE LIKE MARK
KELLY AND THE WOMAN IN THE
BATTLE WITH THREE NAMES AND NO
ACCOMPLISHMENTS AND FETTERMAN
AND WARNOCK.
HE HAD JON OSSOFF, THE OTHER
SENATOR THERE.
THESE GUYS DIDN'T GO DOWN.
I DON'T KNOW IF THEY HAVE GIVEN
UP ON WARNOCK BUT NOBODY WENT
THERE FOR HIM LATELY.
THEY PROBABLY DIDN'T WANT TO BE
NEAR STACEY ABRAMS.
THESE ABOUT A TO BE A TWO-TIME
LOSER.
THIS IS IMPORTANT.
THE DEMOCRATS HAVEN'T BEEN
ANYWHERE NEAR 50% IN THE POLLS
IN A LONG TIME.
THAT'S BAD FOR THE PARTY IN
POWER.
YOU SEE THE NARROW MARGINS.
IN 2020, AT THE HOUSE LEVEL
THERE WERE 27 TOSS-UPS.
REPUBLICANS WON ALL OR MOST OF
THEM.
IN 2018, THERE WERE A NUMBER OF
RACES, 17 RACES NOT CALLED
BECAUSE THEY WERE SO CLOSE.
DEMOCRATS ENDED UP WINNING MOST
OF THOSE.
SO IF YOU DIDN'T GET OUT TO VOTE
YET, DAY OF VOTING IS A RICH
TRADITION IN THIS COUNTRY.
YOU TAKE THE TIME TO DO THINGS
EVERY SINGLE DAY.
INDEPENDENTS, SWING VOTERS, IF
YOU'RE SAYING I HATE BOTH
PARTIES, THEY'RE NOT DIFFERENT,
THE PARTIES HAVE NEVER BEEN MORE
DIFFERENT.
ONE IS FOR ENERGY INDEPENDENCE
AND A SOUND ECONOMY AND LOWER
CRIME.
ONE IS SIMPLY NOT -- ONE DIDN'T
LISTEN TO YOU.
IN ADDITION TO ASKING PEOPLE,
ARE YOU BETTER OFF?
HERE'S THE QUESTION IN 2022.
WHICH PARTY SAW YOU, HEARD YOU,
LISTENED TO YOU AND RESPONDED
TO?
IT'S CLEAR THAT THE REPUBLICANS.
>> Sean: ARI, YOU'RE LOOKING AT
THE BIG PICTURE HERE.
THIS IS NOT YOUR FIRST RODEO.
ALL OF US HAVE BEEN DOWN THIS
ROAD.
ALL OF THE FOUNDATIONAL ISSUES
ARE THERE FOR THE REPUBLICANS TO
HAVE A WAVE ELECTION.
IT DOESN'T HAPPEN UNLESS THE
PEOPLE GET OUT AND VOTE.
THERE'S NOT A SINGLE THING THAT
THEY CAN RUN ON THAT IS A
SUCCESS FOR THEM.
WHERE DO YOU SEE THIS GOING
TOMORROW?
>> THE REPUBLICANS WILL TAKE THE
HOUSE AND THE SENATE.
I THINK THAT'S THAT SIMPLE.
THE FIRST RACE I WORKED ON, SEAN
WAS 1982.
RONALD REAGAN'S FIRST MID-TERM
ELECTION AND THE REPUBLICANS
LOST 26 SEATS.
IT WAS A WAVE FOR THE DEMOCRATS.
A PRESIDENT'S FIRST MID-TERM IS
TOUGH WITH ONE EXCEPTION THE
LAST 60 YEARS AND THAT WAS
GEORGE W. BUSH BECAUSE OF
SEPTEMBER 11th AND HIS GREAT
POPULARITY, HE WON SEATS IN THE
HOUSE AND THE SENATE.
THIS YEAR FOR JOE BIDEN, THE MAN
HAS A 42% JOB APPROVAL.
ABYSMALLY LOW.
THE NATION BY 70% THINKS WE'RE
ON THE WRONG TRACK AND THE
ECONOMY IS TERRIBLE.
MARRY THAT TO A FIRST TERM
ELECTION, IT'S THE KISS OF DEATH
FOR THE PARTY IN POWER.
THE REPUBLICANS WILL TAKE THE
HOUSE AND END UP WITH 230 SEATS.
I THINK REPUBLICANS IN THE
SENATE, I PREDICTED IT TO YOU
LAST WEEK A 25% CHANCE THAT THE
REPUBLICANS WILL GET 56 SEATS.
IT'S A 33% CHANCE NOW.
IT'S BEEN A GOOD WEEK SINCE LAST
WEEK FOR REPUBLICANS.
THE TREND CONTINUES.
REPUBLICANS WILL TAKE THE
SENATE, PROBABLY WITH 53 OR 54
SEATS.
I CAN SEE A 33% CHANCE OF
REPUBLICANS ENDING UP WITH 56
SEATS.
>> Sean: LET ME TAKE A BREAK,
GOVERNOR.
WE'RE GOING TO GET TO YOU IN A
SECOND.
WE'RE GOING TO DIP INTO
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
HE'S IN OHIO.
A BIG CROWD TONIGHT FOR J.D.
VANCE.
HE'S EXPECTED TO MAKE A BIG
ANNOUNCEMENT TONIGHT.
>> THIS IS THE BEGINNING OF
COMMUNISM.
A LOCAL LEFT-WING D.A. IN
ATLANTA IS AFTER ME FOR AN
ABSOLUTELY PERFECT PHONE CALL
ABOUT ELECTION INTEGRITY.
EVEN WHILE ATLANTA HAS AMONG THE
HIGHEST MURDER RATES PER CAPITA
OF ANY CITY IN THE COUNTRY.
THEY'RE WORSE THAN CHICAGO,
WHICH IS A DISASTER.
AND ALL OF THESE LOCAL
DEMOCRAT-RUN CASE ARE BEING
DIRECTED BY WASHINGTON D.C.
IT'S PART OF THE WITCH HUNT.
THE LONGEST IN HISTORY.
I HAVE GONE THROUGH THE LARGEST
WITCH HUNT IN THE HISTORY OF OUR
COUNTRY.
AND IT'S A DISGRACE.
A FRIEND OF MINE, SMART GUY SAID
YOU'VE BEEN GOING THROUGH THIS
FOR 6 1/2 YEARS.
YOU HAVE TO BE THE MOST HONEST
PERSON -- IT'S TRUE.
CAN YOU IMAGINE, 11 MILLION
PAGES OF DOCUMENTS THEY HAVE
EXAMINED AND THEY HAVE NOTHING.
THEY HAVE ONE PERSON THAT
THEY'RE TORTURING ABOUT A
COMPANY OWNED CAR.
DID PAY TAX ON A COMPANY-OWNED
DEPARTMENT.
THEY'RE CALLED FRINGE BENEFITS.
DIDN'TED  -- DIDN'T REPORT I
PAID THE EDUCATION FOR A MAN.
THEY'RE TORTUTORTURING.
THEY WANT HIM TO SAY SOMETHING
BAD ABOUT TRUMP.
FRIEND OF MINE OWNS A BIG
ACCOUNTING FIRM.
HE SAID THERE'S NEVER BEEN A
CASE LIKE THIS BEFORE.
THEY HAVE PERSECUTED THIS MAN IN
ORDER FOR HIM TO SAY SOMETHING
AND THEN ULTIMATELY YOU GO TO
JAIL FOR A COUPLE WEEKS OR A
COUPLE MONTHS OR YOU GO TO JAIL
FOR MANY YEARS.
HE SAID I HAVE TO SAY THIS IS
WHAT -- THINK OF WHAT THEY DID.
ANYBODY OUT HERE WOULD PROBABLY
TAKE A DEAL LIKE THAT.
I WOULDN'T.
I'LL BE HONEST.
BUT THEY TORTURE.
THIS IS WHAT THEY USED TO DO AND
DO CURRENTLY IN COMMUNIST
COUNTRY.
THAT'S WHERE WE'RE GOING.
THINK OF IT.
HANDCUFFS, WALKED IN FRONT, A
MAN THAT NEVER HEARD OF JAIL
BEFORE.
A MAN THAT NEVER HAD A PROBLEM
WITH ANYTHING BEFORE.
HANDCUFFS.
THEY PERP WALKED HIM IN FRONT OF
THE PRESS.
NOBODY HAS EVER BEEN CRIMINALLY
CHARGED FROM WHAT WE UNDERSTAND
ON A FRINGE BENEFIT CASE.
A COMPANY-OWNED CAR.
THINK OF THAT.
DIDN'T PAY TAX ON A
COMPANY-OWNED CAR.
COMPANIED OWN APARTMENT.
THEY SAY THAT VERY FEW PEOPLE
DO.
HOW MANY PEOPLE -- HOW MANY
PEOPLE HAVE A COMPANY OWNED CAR.
DO YOU PAY TAX?
COVER YOUR FACE.
UNCLE SAM, DO YOU HAVE A
COMPANY-OWNED CAR, PLEASE?
I GUARANTEE EVEN UNCLE SAM
DOESN'T PAY TAX.
IT'S A SHAME.
WHEN I SEE WHAT'S GOING ON, IT'S
A SHAME.
OUR COUNTRY HAS GONE TO HELL.
WE HAVE A WEAPONIZED DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE AND A WEAPONITED FBI
INCLUDING RAID OF MAR-A-LARGO IN
THE DOCUMENT CASE.
TOTALLY VIOLATING MY FOURTH
AMENDMENT RIGHTS.
CLINTON, YOU KNOW THE SOCK CASE.
HE HAD THINGS IN HIS SOCKS.
NOTHING HAPPENED TO HIM EXCEPT A
GREAT VERDICT.
WE GO BY THAT VERDICT.
THE SOCKS VERDICT.
NO, HE HAD IT IN HIS SOCKS.
YOU KNOW THAT.
OTHERS TOOK MANY DOCUMENTS.
THEY TAKE THEM OUT OF THE WHITE
HOUSE.
I'M THE ONLY ONE THAT CAN'T TAKE
ANYTHING.
MAYBE OUR COUNTRY WOULD BE
BETTER OFF IF I HAD THE NUCLEAR
CODES, J.D., BECAUSE OUR ENEMIES
WOULD BE AFRAID UNLIKE THE WAY
THEY ARE NOW.
IF I HAD THE NUCLEAR CODES.
BILL CLINTON, HE LOST THE
NUCLEAR CODES TWICE.
HOW DO YOU EXPLAIN THAT TO THE
MILITARY?
I LOST THE MILITARY CODES.
HE LOST THEM TWICE.
I DIDN'T.
THEY'RE COMING AFTER ME BECAUSE
I'M FIGHTING FOR YOU.
THAT'S ALL IT IS.
IF I WASN'T LEADING IN ALL OF
THESE POLLS -- IF YOU FIND THE
POLL NUMBERS, YOU CAN PUT THEM
UP.
IF YOU FIND THEM BACK THERE
EUGENE
IOUS
E US
WE'LL TALK ABOUT THIS.
I THINK THIS IS GOING TO BE A
BIG WAVE.
I HOPE SO.
STARTING RIGHT HERE.
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT.
THAT'S PRESIDENT TRUMP.
HE'S IN THE STATE OF OHIO.
HE'S EXPECTED TO MAKE A BIG
ANNOUNCEMENT.
I'VE BEEN CALLING SOURCES ALL
DAY.
GOVERNOR HUCKABEE, MANY
SPECULATING THAT IN FACT THE
PRESIDENT MAY BE ANNOUNCING THAT
HE'S RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT
TONIGHT.
MY SOURCES SAY THAT THAT WILL
NOT BE THE CASE, THAT HE WILL BE
ANNOUNCING THAT HE'S MADE A
DECISION AND THAT DECISION WILL
BE FORTHCOMING.
WOULD IT HAVE MATTERED IF HE DID
ANNOUNCE TONIGHT?
>> I THINK IT PROBABLY IS BETTER
IF HE HOLDS OFF FOR A LITTLE
WHILE FOR TWO REASONS.
NUMBER 1, EVERYBODY IS FOCUSED
ON THE MID-TERM ELECTIONS
THROUGH TOMORROW NIGHT.
WE NEED TO GET THROUGH THIS.
WE NEED TO PUT ALL THE ATTENTION
ON GETTING OUR VOTERS OUT TO
VOTE AND WIN THE RACES AND TO
WIN THEM BIG.
THE SECOND REASON, HE REALLY
WOULD BE TAKING AWAY FROM THE
FOCUS OF HIS OWN ANNOUNCEMENT.
IN THE MIDST OF THE MID-TERM
ELECTIONS, IF HE WERE TO MAKE
THAT ANNOUNCEMENT TONIGHT,
PEOPLE WOULDN'T BE TALKING ABOUT
IT NEARLY AS MUCH IF HE HAS A
DATE OUT THERE SOMEWHERE IN THE
FUTURE AND HE HAS THE STAGE ALL
TO HIMSELF WITH NOTHING ELSE
GOING ON.
IT WILL GIVE ALL OF THE PRESS
PEOPLE AN OPPORTUNITY TO DO WHAT
THEY LOVE TO DO.
BEAT UP ON HIM.
BY THE WAY, I WANT TO SAY ONE
THING ABOUT CHEF BOYARDEE.
WHEN I WAS A KID GROWING UP, IT
WAS A LUXURY TO HAVE CHEF
BOYARDEE.
ALL OF THESE PEOPLE TALKING
ABOUT IT BEING SOME KIND OF A
PIKER LUNCH.
HECK, MAN, I WOULD BE THRILLED
TO HAVE CHEF BOYARDEE WHEN I WAS
A KID.
>> Sean: I'LL SEND YOU A CASE.
I LIKED IT AS A KID AND LIKED
THE SPAGHETTIOS, TOO.
I COULDN'T GET THERE.
MY DAD LIKE CORNED HASH AND
DINTY MOORE BEEF STEW.
IF MY SOURCES ARE CORRECT AND
ONLY THAT HE MADE UP HIS MIND
AND WILL BE ANNOUNCING IN THE
FUTURE, IS THAT A HINT?
HOW DO YOU TAKE THAT?
>> IT SHOULDN'T WITH A SURPRISE
TO ANYONE.
HE MADE IT CLEAR THAT DONALD
TRUMP AGREES WITH THE MAJORITY
OF DEMOCRATS, THAT HE DOESN'T
WANT BIDEN THERE IN 2024 EITHER.
IF THIS COULD BE A BINARY CHOICE
BETWEEN THE ECONOMY, ENERGY,
SECURITY, CRIME UNDER DONALD
TRUMP AND BORDER, OF COURSE, AND
UNDER JOE BIDEN, THEN I THINK
IT'S EASY.
BUT LOOK, DONALD TRUMP HAS BEEN
DOING WHAT YOU SEE HIM DOING
RIGHT THERE ON THE SPLIT SCREEN.
HE'S BEEN DOING THIS 1 1/2 YEARS
NOW.
HE ENDORSED CANDIDATES, HE WROTE
CHECKS TO THEM.
HIS MAGA INC. HAS SPENT MILLIONS
IN FIVE STATES, ESPECIALLY HE'S
SHOWED UP, STOOD UP, SPOKEN UP
AND PUT UP FOR THESE CANDIDATES.
CONTRAST THIS WITH THE CURRENT
PRESIDENT WHO CAN'T STAND AT THE
PODIUM.
HE WAS IN MARYLAND TODAY, NOT A
SWING STATE.
HE WAS IN UNION STATION THE
OTHER DAY.
NOT A SWING STATE.
IT'S A TRAIN STATION.
AND THE PRESIDENT WENT THERE TO
GIVE SOME ROUSING SPEECH.
HE WAS IN NEW YORK, HE WAS IN
CALIFORNIA.
SO LOOK, I THINK THAT A NUMBER
OF PEOPLE DESERVE A LOT OF
CREDIT FOR THIS GOING THE
REPUBLICANS WAY.
BUT THAT INCLUDES DONALD TRUMP.
HE WILL HAVE A LOT OF GOOD TO
SAY ABOUT THE CANDIDATES HE
ENDORSED, THE WAY HE DID THE
TELETOWN HALLS AND THE ISSUES
SET.
THE AMERICA FIRST ISSUE SET IS
ON THE BALLOT NO ARI, WE'LL HAVE
TO GIVE YOU THE LAST WORD AND
GOVERNOR HUCKABEE WILL NO LONGER
BE THE BEST GOVERNOR IN ARKANSAS
HISTORY.
WHAT IS YOUR TALK ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT NOT ANNOUNCING BUT
SAYING HE'S MADE UP HIS MIND?
>> YEAH, HE'S A WONDERFUL
TEASER, ISN'T HE?
HE DOES KNOW HOW TO GET THE
FOCUS ON HIM.
I THINK GOVERNOR HUCKABEE IS
EXACTLY RIGHT.
REPUBLICANS WANT TO HAVE THE
FOCUS ON JOE BIDEN THROUGH
ELECTION DAY.
THAT'S THE REASON THAT
REPUBLICANS HAVE BEEN PROPELLED
TO SUCH SUCCESS.
JOE BIDEN IS A VERY UNPOPULAR
PRESIDENT.
KEEP THE FOCUS ON JOE BIDEN.
WHATEVER THE PRESIDENT DOES,
PRESIDENT TRUMP DOES AFTER THAT,
THEN WE'LL SEE.
THEN I THINK IT'S A FASCINATING
ISSUE ABOUT WHETHER ANYBODY
CHALLENGES DONALD TRUMP.
I'M CERTAIN HE'S GOING TO RUN.
I CAN'T IMAGINE WITH ALL THE
TEASING HE'S DONE THAT HE WILL
PULL BACK.
I'M PRETTY SURE THAT PRESIDENT
DONALD TRUMP WILL RUN AGAIN IN
THE REPUBLICAN NOMINATION AND
ALL THE ATTENTION SHIFTS TO WILL
SOMEBODY CHALLENGE HIM.
>> Sean: WE'LL FIND OUT.
WE'LL GO BACK TO OUR COVERAGE OF
THAT.